right so if you want to travel outside
the country you need a passport but
right now getting one is proving to be a
very lengthy process yeah the wait times
are long getting an appointment's pretty
tough Candace Charles joins us live this
morning from one of our passport centers
it's a Post Office right off sunset for
the reason for this unprecedented demand
Candace good morning to you
good morning YouTube good morning folks
the U.S travel Association says about 52
percent of Americans plan to travel in
the next six months with 500 000
applications coming into the U.S
Department of State a week for those
passports you can expect that there's
going to be wait time and they suggest
that you plan ahead like some of these
folks have done coming here early to get
their names on the list before it opens
at 8 and possibly be willing to travel
now the secretary of state says the 2022
fiscal year has a record number of 22
million password books books issued
we're now on track to break that record
there are 60 passport centers in Nevada
10 of them are in Las Vegas and
Henderson and many of them are
appointment only the problem is
appointments are now two to four months
out and if you plan to walk in you can
expect to wait but here's what you can
do
be patient explore many options there's
probably about 20 places in the county
you can get an appointment a lot of them
are booked but do some legwork keep
checking websites people do cancel
appointments you might get lucky
yes I hope it's to get lucky now the
windmill Library only does first time
applications renewals for minors like
many of the locations here in Nevada
after you get the appointment the
standard processing time for a passport
is 10 to 13 weeks 7-9 for expedited but
if you just need a renewal you can apply
online and mail in the application along
with your picture and your expired
passport now we will have more details
on that on our website newsnow.com
coming up here with the secretary of
state says it's the reason for all of
this weight besides lots of people being
willing to go ahead and travel out the
country now I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now